a deadly shooting at the Tree of Life
synagogue in Pittsburgh what happened at
the Tree of Life synagogue is the
deadliest attack on Jewish Americans in
US history
empathetic is that the word if you feel
for people I'm feeling it a lot today
because I'm Jewish I'm gonna talk about
it all night that's what I'm gonna do
are there Jewish people here great hey
where'd you go to camp so I am some of
you think I mean the Holocaust because
you're not educated but I meant
sleepaway camp and the Jewish people
always laugh because we've had loss
black people laugh a lot too because
they've had loss some of you don't even
know what I'm talking about
what kind of loss what the happened
is that Kirstie Alley when it comes to
the shooting stuff if I have a joke
about that it better be really great it
better be great and it better be
honestly I don't think I don't believe
in too soon I believe you've got to
figure out like you got to figure out
your formula to get away with I'm Jewish
is it bad I don't want to make light
about what happens it's just
anti-semitism is coming back and it's
very anti-semitism is one of the like
it's some of the dumbest people I know
they always make these ridiculous
accusations against the Jews or I was
like Jews secretly run the banks like no
we're pretty open about that actually
it's not really a secret goldman sachs
we put our name on the building twice
that's very overt Lehman Brothers
Salomon Brothers JPMorgan the Jay P
stands for Jewish people that's not what
did you hear Jessica Carson got accosted
by a jewelers in the crowd she made a
comment about the synagogue shooting and
basically she said the guy should be
raped in prison with the menorah and
this woman was like shut up you can't
say that
you want to just feel like comedy
club that's what you signed up for but I
do feel like when they give when they
give people about what stories you
tell about things that now even things
that happen to you on stage like you're
taking away our coping mechanisms not
just how big is a man or eight right I
love that that was your follow-up
question I hope that that guy has to go
to prison forever and I would love to
hear that he got raped with a menorah I
have to be honest with you okay um
what'd you say what's terrible a whole
day I so glad I have a heckler right now
this is amazing
you're probably from Israel it's very
upsetting i under I know I know I'm a
sinner I'm also married to a woman so
that's not okay either so I'm already a
sinner
shut the up
shut up you shut up you shut up let's do
this the whole time you shut up you shut
up you shut up let me do it as a black
woman she's getting upset she's a super
Jew she's a super Jew shares also
fortune
[Applause]
you